[Musique]
comment chatouiller un poisson
[Musique] l'
une des premières choses qu'ils vous enseignent
en plongée sous-marine est de ne pas toucher les
animaux
vous risquez de vous blesser
mais surtout vous avez une chance de
blesser l'animal aussi
maintenant  je sais qu'on dirait que ce rey
rit quand ce gars le chatouille
mais c'est un cas classique d'
anthropomorphisme qui est où nous
attribuons des caractéristiques et des
comportements humains
aux animaux et aux objets non humains
en réalité c'est une situation très très stressante
pour le rayon
pensez-y comme ceci, euh, ce rayon est
censé respirer de l'
eau et maintenant il est dans l'air et
quelqu'un le
force à ouvrir la bouche et à laisser sortir
toute l'eau dont il a besoin et à la
remplacer par de l'air
alors rappelez-vous les gars tous  ces vidéos
que nous voyons en ligne d'animaux faisant des
choses mignonnes peuvent sembler
amusantes et inoffensives pour nous, mais en réalité, cela
peut être une expérience traumatisante pour l'
animal
[Musique]
si vous saviez que chatouiller un loris lent
est en fait une torture
ce loris a les bras levés parce qu'elle est
terrifiée
et essaie de se protéger en
recueillant le venin d'une glande à l'intérieur de son
coude
[Musique]
les loris lents souffrent terriblement
à cause du commerce d'animaux de compagnie
alimenté par ces vidéos avant qu'un loris lent ne
soit  vendu comme animal de compagnie
ses dents sont enlevées sans
esthétique les
loris sont passés en contrebande dans des
conteneurs sans air sombres et surpeuplés aux côtés des corps
d'autres loris
qui sont morts
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]